atomic blonde comes to us from one of
the directors of the first John wick and
star Charlize Theron as a super badass
spy in 1989 in Berlin right around the
time the Berlin Wall was about to fall
so there's a lot of political unrest
Wars in the streets riots between people
and cops we are talking about 1989 right
but that's just the setting Charlize
Theron's as Lorraine is trying to get a
list a list of very important people
that has been put out in the open and
James McAvoy is trying to help her as
well and she's also trying to protect
certain people and she's also telling
this story to John Goodman and Toby
Jones and there's a lot going on in this
story and the things that work the most
about atomic blonde are it's incredible
style it's a beautifully shot movie it
looks amazing
Charlize is excellent in this role and
similar to John wick this director
proves once again that he's terrific at
helming hand-to-hand combat scenes car
chases he makes it all look wonderful
and some of the same stunt people worked
on this movie that made John wick 1 & 2
even some of the same stunt actors when
the action sequences are going down in
particular a standout sequence inside a
stairwell that eventually goes into the
streets of Berlin this movie is a blast
Charlize really kicks a lot of ass in
the main title role she clearly went
through a lot of stunt training and she
sells every single minute of it sofia
boutella is also really great in this
movie once again although highly
underutilized unfortunately and James
McAvoy once again is devilishly
entertaining I'm convinced the man can
do no wrong as an actor but at the same
time this movie disappointed me from a
storytelling perspective they chose to
have Charlize in the very beginning sit
down and tell a story to people now
she's covered in bruises and she's got a
black eye so you know she's gonna get
her ass beat but she is sitting there
telling this story and a lot of movies
do this and I don't always appreciate
that structure choice because it takes a
lot of tension out of the movie because
you know that she's probably gonna be
just fine in the long run because she's
sitting there telling us a story
in the opening scene so I think if they
had allowed the narrative to play out
from beginning to end from A to Z the
movie would have been more entertaining
and there would
been more tension and a little more
stakes I would have cared a little more
as well because we constantly cut back
to this story that she's sitting in this
interrogation room and she's talking
about these things that happened and
whenever it does that I felt like the
movie just screeched to a halt because
unfortunately those sequences were very
dry and this lead character is so badass
and so cool that I was very intrigued
for a long time about her character and
I was invested and I was interested
because I was very excited to learn more
intrigue can only go so far though
because at some point you have to learn
something about this lead character and
I realized when the movie was almost
over that I hadn't and the fact that I
was intrigued by her character and
wanted to learn more about her faded
away when I realized I wasn't going to
now some movies can make that work like
Dunkirk for instance last week that was
such a brutal and effective war movie
because I learned from the characters
actions from the things they did in this
singular moment and it was about a
moment in history
atomic blonde on the other hand has a
sprawling and complex narrative that is
filled with so many twists and turns and
by the end of the film I was honestly
struggling to figure out what exactly
the characters motivations were you can
watch the movie and be like okay she's
trying to get that list and so is he and
those people are working together to get
that list and those people want to sell
the list and that all makes sense that's
just the MacGuffin the thing that
everyone is after that's not what's
difficult to understand at all what is
is everyone's motivations because every
character pretty much presents themself
to be something and then ends up being
something completely different but you
don't really get enough time to learn
why who where what how it all just kind
of happens there's a lot of twists and
turns and this is definitely more of a
spy movie than Jane wick which is what a
lot of the trailers are trying to make
you think no doubt there's action
sequences and every single one of them
is extremely well done but this is
definitely more of a complex spy movie
that has bursts of action and then one
balls-out incredible action scene that
is admittedly one of the better action
scenes I've seen there just wasn't
enough to
me invested in Charlize his character
there is one dream sequence that hints
that she had knowledge of something that
we didn't know she had knowledge of but
it's not enough there's not enough meat
there for me to really care so yeah
she's beautiful she kicks ass she looks
good in all of her outfits but in the
end it made it hard for me to actually
give a shit about what she was doing or
why she was doing it
another thing highly stylized about
atomic blonde is the soundtrack not just
the choices of songs but the way in
which they're utilized into the Edit
there's one scene in particular where
Charlize is walking into a bar and you
hear dark hummus start playing I don't
turn around now song and you're thinking
okay it's playing on the speakers but
then she sits down and a hand comes into
frame with a lighter and the lighter
flicks on and then the song just cuts
there's barely a single fade and now
you're hearing background stereotypical
jazz bar music I'm thinking to myself
wait so was that song not playing in the
bar and they just played that because it
was a big hit back then that's the way
this soundtrack works it can actually
get a little abrasive and rather
overwhelming they were definitely trying
to make the soundtrack stand out and it
did but probably not in the best way it
was a big long track list of 80s hits
that didn't really mesh with the movie
and sometimes it can get so heavy that
it's really all you notice just in the
first like half hour there were at least
two or three times where a song will be
very low in the background and in the
second Charlize shoots kicks or punches
someone it blares up to 11 it gets
really loud whenever someone's getting
their ass beat there were a lot of
editorial choices that came off more
showy than something that actually added
to the story or improved the characters
and that's really my major issue if I
were to just boil it down into one thing
with atomic blonde
it's the final cut of the movie I think
that there is actually a really damn
good movie here but it's told in a very
convoluted and messy way and flashback
form and then flash forward form and
there's a lot of music choices that
became very overwhelming in the end I'm
gonna give atomic blonde a C+
guys what did you think of a Tomic
blonde if you got a chance to see it as
always if you like this you can click
right here and get stuck my eyes
[Music]